Hello and welcome to I'd like to know
our Bible question and answer program.
You've got questions from the Bible.
We've got answers from the Bible and the
Bible has answers to all of your
questions. So, thank you for sharing
part of your busy day with us. My name
is CA Murray. To my left, Pastor David
Salazar. to my right, Pastor Steven Bar.
Gentlemen, good to have you here. Good
to study the word of God with you.
>> Amen.
>> We want to encourage you to send in your
Bible questions to us. We love to study
the word of God. We love to answer your
questions. You can do so by sending your
questions to tvsumsv.org.
That's tvsumtv.org.
And we will answer your questions just
as quickly as we possibly can. Thank you
once again for being part of our family
and for sending in your questions to us.
Pastor Boore, if you would ask God's
blessing upon our sitting today, we'll
get right into our first question.
>> Father in heaven, we come before your
awesome and powerful throne. We come
boldly because we come in the name of
Jesus.
We know that you have promised that when
we pray in faith, you answer our
prayers.
>> Amen.
>> So, we ask for your presence in this
program. first of all that your name
might be honored and glorified and that
uh we might be able to answer these
questions satisfactorily for those who
have asked them. We ask that especially
what we study today will be useful in
our personal walk with the Lord.
>> Amen.
>> This we thank you for in the precious
name of Jesus. Amen.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. And amen. Our first question comes
to us from Guyana and we want to thank
you for letting us know where the
question is coming from. That helps us
so very very much. It the name is Jaffer
Vifas
and I hope I got that right. I probably
butchered it up a little bit but
[laughter] you know it comes from the
head the heart not the head. Jaffrey,
thank you for your question. It's a
little lengthy but we want to uh give it
due diligence. I've recently discovered
your church and channel uh through a
breakthrough period in my life and I've
fallen in love with how you teach the
Bible. Well, that that's good news and
we praise the Lord for that.
>> As someone who grew up in a church where
the seven the Sabbath day isn't honored,
I used to judge Seventh Day Adventist
congregations for being backward. Uh
that was until recently when I learned
the actual truth about the Sabbath and
how much the Catholic Church influence
uh influence has dominated churches
around the world. Okay, preamble. Now
the question, I want to start honoring
the Sabbath day the right way, but I
also want do not want to turn my back on
my church. My question is how should
someone like me go about such a
transition?
I think there are a number of issues
that that uh are brought up here. You
want to honor the Lord once you've made
a decision to follow the Bible.
That presupposes some other kinds of
decisions. It means you're you're going
to follow a church that teaches the
truth, the whole truth, and nothing but
the truth.
>> Amen. If your church does not do that,
then you've got a a decision to make
right away. Is my church important to me
or is the word of God most important to
me?
>> Once you make that decision, then a
number of other decisions fall into
line. So, you want to honor the word of
God. You want to serve the word of God.
Well, then you've got to plant yourself
in a church that does precisely that.
And if your church is not doing that,
then you are going to have to think
about seriously severing ties with that
church. Now, severing ties with the
church does not necessarily mean
severing ties with the people or with
the friendship you've made. In fact, I
think the Lord would call you to share
the new light that you have found with
those from that other fraternity. So you
don't want to cut off friendships per
se, but as far as participation in
acceptance of uh attending regularly,
you're going to have to move from the
non-commandment church to the total
commandment keeping church and that will
call for that decision to be made on on
your part.
>> Pastor David, pastor.
>> Yeah, I I I totally agree with what you
said, Pastor CA. uh the Bible, the
scripture is clear that once you
understand truth uh that truth calls you
for obedience to the truth, not partial
commitment. Um [clears throat]
Jesus actually said in Matthew 6:24, "No
one can serve two masters. You can't now
that you understand the light on a
particular subject specifically uh such
an importance of the seven day Sabbath."
And I say it's importance because it not
only is not only the fourth commandment,
not only reminds you who the creator is,
not only tells you where and and how
you're supposed to worship God, but also
remember that in Ezekiel 2012, it's
mentions and I'm going to read basically
there that he gave us the Sabbath for a
reason. It says, "Moreover, I also gave
them my Sabbaths to be a sign between
them and me that they may know that I am
the Lord who sanctifies them." So the
Lord is asking us by keeping the Sabbath
to understand that we're in a
relationship with God. We are accepting
his rulership over my life and that he
calls me to obey that truth, that
knowledge to be part of that that sign
that he has given me. So Jesus said, "If
you love me and my commandments, it's
very clear from the Bible that love and
truth will, you know, will when they
come to your heart, you're going to obey
them and be committed fully to that." So
that commission or that commitment to
the new light means in many cases
sometimes having to separate yourself
and to part ways from that which was is
in error. And so I know that he wants to
have the relationship with his previous
church, but he has to make the decision.
Do I become faithful to the Lord? Am I
faithful to God and his word and his
law? Or do I continue
accommodating to my will, you know, it
it basically comes down to that. So I
think that he needs to be like Paul,
like Peter, like the disciples. Uh Peter
said, I rather serve God than men. So
that's really what he needs to make the
decision. And once he makes that
decision uh like you said pastor CA the
friendships the fellowship with those
who he has been in contact for many
years he has to keep that and cherish
that and try to give them the light with
with love with patience but at the same
time use his influence for good. Uh but
that does not mean that he has to
continue being a member of a church that
is in error and that rejects the light
of the word of God.
>> Thank you pastor. I just want to add one
thing and that is that um the message
that Jafari has seen uh either on social
media or on television is only one
aspect of the truth that is not being
followed
>> by other churches.
>> Yeah.
>> It's not only the Sabbath, it's the
state of the dead. It's what the Bible
says about hell. It's about healthful
living. In other words, there there are
many many teachings that the 7th Day
Adventist Church teaches
>> that are not being followed by other
churches. Yeah.
>> And so, uh, you know, if you go to
another church where they believe that
hell burns forever and you go to hell
when you die and that your soul leaves
the body when you die and goes to heaven
or goes to hell, uh, you know, uh, then
uh, it becomes much much more complex
>> because he might be able to argue, well,
you know, I'll on Sabbath I'll just keep
Sabbath at home, then I'll continue
going to my uh, Sunday church on Sunday.
Uh but really um my council would be uh
to uh keep in touch with friends,
>> members of the other church, take
advantage of the opportunity to witness
to those people
>> so that they can embrace the truth
>> and continue studying the other elements
of truth
>> that uh that are not being taught by the
church that he belongs to. and uh and
then uh witness as much as you can about
all those other doctrines as well.
>> Amen. Well said. You know, I I'll tell
you a quick story. I had a a friend. He
was he was a friend when I was at
>> 3ABN.
>> He actually used to attend the 7th
Adventist church on Saturday, sit in
Sabbath school class,
>> take notes, and then go teach Sunday
school class
>> on Sunday and teach everything he taught
on that he learned on Sabbath. Yeah.
>> But after a while, the church became
wise [laughter] and and they kicked him
out. They said, "No, you can't come
teaching that stuff." So he he tried to
sit on both sides of the fence, you
know, two shoes, but you can't have two
passports. You can only really have your
your passport in one fraternity. So he
tried it for a while. It did not work.
And uh this has been a few years. And of
course, he's safely ensconced in the
Adventist church now. But he tried it.
It didn't it didn't work. Sooner or
later, you have to make a decision. and
and coming to Christ means making
decisions to turn your back on the
world, to turn your back on error, to
turn your back on partial truth because
partial truth is still a lie. Yes.
>> Uh and you can't you can't deal.
>> One one thing one more thing I want to
say is um what Jafari says in this u
message that he sent us indicates that
uh he grew up in a church where Sabbath
was not honored.
>> Mhm. And he probably um you know he says
I used to judge the 7th Adventist
congregation for being backward. So in
other words he was biased towards
uh rejecting the Sabbath.
>> Yes.
>> But the good thing is that he had an
open mind.
>> Amen. All said
>> and and so he said you know I'm going to
evaluate this from the Bible myself. I'm
going to do my own research and I've
concluded that the Sabbath is the day
we're supposed to keep. So in other
words uh you know we can change our mind
when we discover new truth if we have an
open heart.
>> Amen. Amen.
>> Blessed
>> and pastor you know there is this verse
that Christ mentioned that I think um
our brother Jafari needs to remember
>> and it's uh Mark 7
6 or Mark 7:7 actually. And Jesus is
actually quoting here from the Old
Testament. And he said um I'll read
actually six and seven. He answered and
said to them, "Well did Isaiah prophesy
of you hypocrites as it is written,
these people honor me with their lips,
but their hearts is far from me and in
vain they worship me, teaching as
doctrines the commandments of men." Mhm.
You know, you have to remember that if
your previous church is teaching
doctrines that are contrary to the
Bible, that are not longer in harmony
with the truth that you have received,
that you understand, that you have
clearly understood from the Bible, you
can't actively participate or be
comfortable in that environment because
again, you're putting then men's
opinion, men's traditions, men's
teachings over the word of God. And and
the Bible and the truth separates. It
makes a a clear
separation of those who honor God and
want to follow his commandment and his
whole truth and calls us to leave and
depart from that experience of being in
in in ignorance or being in darkness and
called us to be in that marvelous light.
So we have to make a decision and I know
might be hard for him but if God has
given you this understanding of the
scriptures the time has been is I think
is is now for him to make the decision
to join the Adventist church the faith
and understand and
you know leave his old congregation
behind and that's what I will appeal to
our friend Jafari as he has understood
the concept of the truth
>> you know I I would say you know the
Bible says by truth sell it not don't
accept anything
just because it was handed down to you.
You know, Isaiah, you're you were in
Isaiah Isaiah chapter 1:18. Come, let us
reason together.
>> So, if you discover that this is not
truth and this is truth,
>> your duty to God and to yourself is to
follow truth.
>> Yeah.
>> Amen.
>> To follow truth.
>> We don't even ask you to accept blindly
everything you hear on this channel.
>> Of course not.
>> You know, if if it's in the word of God,
we preach it. We teach it. We are
commanded to do so. But if you can't
find backup in the word of God, then
it's just the opinion of men. And you
don't want to follow the opinion of men.
You want your faith, your salvation,
your eternity to be rested on, resting
on the word of God. So reason your way
through and when you see error, step out
of it and follow truth and you will be
pleasing to the Lord. All righty. Uh
we'd like to go to question number our
second question which is Rud these Rud
Rudo Rudyro Rudyro Ruda Vero this is
it's a she she says here we don't know
where this question is coming from but
it has several parts so we'll try to
work our way through it and I suspect
this will take up the rest of our time
for this particular broadcast I'd like
to ask what does the Bible truly say
about tithing in our time many pastors
avoid this question and I hope you
won't. I guarantee you we won't. Uh the
Bible mentions giving 10% of one's
increase. But today most of us uh earn
fixed salaries and rarely uh that rarely
increase maybe once or twice a year if
we're fortunate.
Um there also there's also the question
of tithing from the gross or net income.
In many developing countries, deductions
like taxes or pensions offer little or
no benefit. So, should tithing be based
on the gross income? Let's just take
those two questions and wrestle with
those a little bit and then go down
because she's got four. And um they're
not really that difficult questions,
though they may seem to be once you've
made a decision to trust the Lord. I've
I've had members, pastors come to me and
say, "Here's my check.
>> Here's my expenses. I can't pay tithe.
You know, the the numbers just don't add
up. But tithing, as you both well know,
is not just an issue of what you do.
It's what you believe. It's what's in
your heart. It's a faith issue. If you
had enough money to meet all your needs,
you wouldn't need any faith. You just
pay your money.
>> But tithe presupposes, Lord, you've
given me enough to do what I need to do
and what you want me to do. You've made
that statement when you pay your tithe.
So, um, because the numbers don't
necessarily add up doesn't mean that you
get an excuse or a pass from paying the
tithe. Pastor Boy,
>> you know, I get the impression from the
first question,
uh, and maybe I'm wrong, I'm reading
wrong. Uh, but, uh, what uh, she is
saying is that we should pay tithe on
the increase of our salary.
I don't know whether you whether you're
getting that. The Bible mentions giving
10% of one's increase.
>> Of one's increase.
>> But today, most of us earn fixed
salaries.
>> So,
>> ah, I see what you're saying. Yes. Yes.
Yes.
>> So, is she talking about that we only
tithe
>> the increase that we receive in our
salary? That's the impression.
>> If you got your salary and you got a
raise, you just tithe the raise and not
the salary.
>> Right. That's that's way that could be
taken that way.
>> That's a good question. And I think
pastor I mean maybe [clears throat] our
friend with Averro needs to um you know
maybe do a little more studying on
tithing to understand clearly that the
tithing is not is not just an Old
Testament teaching. It's not a Mosaic
teaching either. It's a concept that is
rooted in scripture from Genesis all the
way till Revelation. And tithing it's
the
best way to develop a trusting
relationship with the Lord is the way
that he implemented for us to see not
only his hand in our lives and how he
can multiply that which is left for us
but also to grow in that relationship in
that trust in that faith. And this is
why of all the uh ordinances that the
Lord has given us it's one he
specifically says prove me test me. Mhm.
>> You know, put your trust in me and
you'll see that I will not fail you. And
the tithing is not of just the increase
as she's asking here. It seems to be the
case. The 10% is of your income, of your
salary, whatever that is. You are to
give a tenth of that. And the tithing is
the the minimum element to return and
then there's offerings which are also to
to return to the Lord. But again, it's a
concept of relationship with God of
trust in the Lord. and um she she kind
of says that a lot of pastors avoid this
question and and I find it interesting
maybe I don't know if she's uh going to
an Adventist congregation or not you
know particularly we don't know that for
sure um and perhaps part of the reason
why uh pastors avoid it in her
experience maybe they are not very clear
on what tithing means or how to approach
it in a situation where there's a
limited income she mentions there in in
in the other part where church leaders
live in luxury And again that may be the
case of uh I don't know other
denominations
uh because I don't see I don't think
that in our denomination in the
Adventist denomination there is such a
thing of a pastor living in luxury as as
they don't have a a you know a huge
income. So maybe there's some things in
her experience that have given her a a a
fear of giving tithe, maybe misused by
leadership, maybe not under not being
explained biblically by their pastors.
But once you understand in the Bible
that tithe is God's way for you to have
a relationship with him and clearly
connect and develop even a growing
relationship with God, you will find it
a joy to give uh a must as it's kind of
like an investment a sound investment in
your own experience.
You know, I I'll try and make it as
simple as possible because the question
is um do we second question is do we
tithe the gross or the net?
So, so in January I get my salary in
January
and I tithe
the salary that I received the gross.
The next month you don't have to tithe
that again
because that was your increase. So the
next month you tithe your salary again
because that's increasing your income.
In other words, uh tithing is based on
on
the additional money that you receive
that you don't have now.
>> Uh and and so God expects us to tithe
the gross,
>> not the net. Because if we tithe the
net, there's nothing left over to tithe,
>> right?
>> If you if you tithe after you pay your
bills, [laughter]
>> yeah, because you you could you could
argue and say, you know, taxes is one
bill and you know, let me pay everything
else and you know, and once I'm done,
that's that's going to give you like you
said, you're making
>> you have very little left
>> left. In other words, it has to be from
your gross. Correct.
>> Yeah. and and and a paying your light
bill is not more important than paying
God. You know, you can run light bill,
water bill, garbage, trash, uh clothing,
furniture, and then you got about $5
less. Okay, Lord, you get tenth of that.
>> So, you cannot put these other things
before God, which which says God has got
to come first. Now, there there is a
couple other things that she asked. I
don't know any any Adventist pastors.
There may be some, but I don't know that
who are living in sumptuous, you know,
maybe not hand-to-mouth, but I don't
know anybody. I've not been in any
palaces or or castles uh inhabited by
Adventist pastors.
>> Uh it all depends what your frame of
reference is. Uh
>> if if a person a very poor person
because uh she mentions uh here $250
with two children
>> uh faithfully tithing while church
leaders live in luxury. Well, a person
who makes $250 a month, a pastor makes a
lot more. So it might appear from that
frame of reference that the pastor is
living luxuriously.
>> Uh so I think that's what she's saying.
um you know one person's luxury
[laughter] is not necessarily another
person's luxury.
>> Um we need to understand that pastors um
have gone to school. They've invested a
significant amount of money in school
and because of their educational level
uh they make more than some of the
members of the church. But as far as
living in luxury, you know, I've never
known a pastor that has a Lamborghini
uh or you know, I I know some that have
a Mercedes-Benz, but usually it's an
older model. Uh so, uh you know,
probably the best counsel is not to be
looking at what somebody else is doing,
but being faithful yourself
>> in in tithing and returning to God what
belongs to God. But now in this accord
pastor, you know, and this is where I
might have a question whether or not
she's a seminist or not. Uh because in a
lot of the other denominations, there's
not this accountability. There's the
system of of of pastors to collect money
sometimes is just from the congregation.
And this is where we have in other
denominations pastors who live like
royalty. I mean, you can see men who
have, you know, planes [clears throat]
and things of that nature.
>> Yeah. The mega mega pastor. the mega
pastors, you know, and we have that in
other denominations, but in the
Adventist denomination, the system is
way much more transparent. There is no,
you know, the tie that you receive in
the local creation, it does not stay
with the pastor is sent to the
conference office and and is worked in
the division and is, you know, so what
I'm saying is it may be in the scenario
uh where she has seen luxurious people
living uh it may be in another
denomination. Um and so I think that uh
perhaps it is the case you know and and
like you said if if if somebody is poor
in the congregation and compared to that
individual maybe a pastor or individual
the leadership is living you know
better. We have to understand that it's
not necessarily because that person is
stealing or or robbing or or is using
the funds. He just has the a set salary
that the conference the local conference
assigns to. And we need to look into
Christ and like you said, let's put the
problems or the issues in the God's
hands so that he can [clears throat]
help that individual grow. And I believe
that as we are faithful, God will again
multiply that which was left and we'll
be able to uh continue to be faithful to
him. And that's what really tithing is
about.
>> One of the things I think we need to
remember that God claims a tithe as his
own. So when you pay your tithe, you're
not giving God anything. You're just
returning to him what he claims as his
own. You're not stealing from him. So
you're you're you're at point zero. Then
what you add to that is really your your
gift to God. The tithe is just you
giving back to God what he has claimed
as as his own. Pastor.
>> Yeah. Well, time is just about up. But
uh there's two kinds of people in the in
the world. The rich and those who envy
the rich. [laughter]
>> So don't look at what other persons are
doing. Just be faithful yourself. Amen.
>> Amen. Amen.
>> Well, our time is gone. It's fast lifted
into eternity. In closing, we wish you
both grace and peace. We'll see you
again next time and God bless you.